friend of the program joel cloud is back
here on the rich eisen show how are you
joel
good what's going on bud how are you
doing oh boy i'm um i've been very
you know my kids i've got a 13 a 10 and
an eight okay and they have used a word
i'd never heard of before
it's a combination of nervous and
excited i'm nervous sighted for
saturday's game
i'm a nervous sided man
for kickoff oh man on saturday that
seems like every test i ever took in my
uh school days nervous um
man i i could not be more excited for
this one this this is you know that
there are
there are some rivalries out there that
are great obviously but there there are
ones also that probably fly a little bit
under the radar from a national
perspective but because of the blurred
lines of the fan bases have more vitriol
to them this is one of those and i mean
they there is no love love loss between
the players uh the fan bases and this
one should be excellent um i i can't
remember obviously a time
that this rivalry meant so much to both
programs and meant so much to college
football in general i mean the last time
they were both in the top ten to face
each other was 1964. so this should be
an absolute blood laugh and i am here
for it and they've never been 7-0 each
of them coming into this game as well
um so
let's let's talk about um michigan state
a little bit um they beat miami earlier
this year
um and and so uh you know you take a
look at the rest northwestern youngstown
state nebraska western kentucky rutgers
indiana so they haven't seen a team as
as composed and stout
um as michigan how do you see michigan
state matching up in this game well
i think that michigan state has done
such a good job of forming an identity
and and playing to that identity in a
short time under their their head coach
mel tucker this is only his second year
and granted they've done a lot of things
in in the transfer portal so they've got
a lot of new players 40 new players on
their team this year that weren't there
a year ago and they're getting a huge
contribution from a lot of those guys
kenneth walker is one of those guys he's
the transfer
that came in and has
really transformed their running game
comes in from from wake and
he's been terrific leading rusher in the
country but i think more than anything
else it's their it's their toughness and
their mentality you know mel tucker was
at colorado i got to know him pretty
well when he was there and he's
unapologetically tough everything in
practice is about competition and
toughness everything in the weight room
is about competition and toughness he is
very disciplined about the the style of
player that he wants uh the mentality of
the player and also the frame of the
player if you look around at this roster
he has built this in the mold of more of
an sec roster they're much faster on
defense rich than they have been in the
past and they're much longer on the
outside you look they've got two corners
both transfer portal guys they came in
one from florida one from alabama bama
ronald williams and chester kimbrough
they're both over six foot tall ronald
williams is six foot two so
he's doing things because of his history
in the sec trying to bring an sec style
of defense to the big ten where they get
after the quarterback they're long on
the outside and they get great
linebacker play they've got one of the
best pass rushers in college football
jacob panashup who is just behind aidan
hutchinson so this is a team that will
run it well they're explosive on offense
uh with a couple of good wide receivers
and they're fast on defense and long on
defense and i think i think michigan is
in for a very tough road because this
this team is going to be ready for him
and michigan has shown an inability to
be explosive in the passing game and you
know the spartans are going to be
loading up on that run game for the
wolverine well in terms of that with the
passing game explosive for michigan
you've seen jj mccarthy uh the
second string quarterback on the depth
chart behind cade mcnamara who's just
looks you know he plays football like
harbaugh did for michigan to be honest
with you
moxie and intelligence and toughness and
taking care of the ball and being a
perfect extension for harbaugh in the
same way that jim was for beau back in
the day
uh and he's made one mistake that
michigan was able to overcome which was
a an interception in the second half
against nebraska but mccarthy a lot as a
big play ability and you see jim kind of
dabble with him
a little bit do you think like what are
you have you had conversations about
harbaugh about why and what and and
maybe it's for games like this now that
they're taking on the states michigan
penn and and and ohio for for for this
moment
i have uh as well as josh gattis the
offensive coordinator
and i think it's fascinating because in
this day and age you know i think it's
easy for coaches to scare themselves
into a situation where they have to play
one or the other
and
and also they scare themselves into or
get pressured into via their fan base to
play the more talented player all the
time and the one with more recruiting
stars mccarthy if no one knows out there
is a five-star recruit he's a true
freshman kate mcnamara he's he's a more
veteran guy
and he's a little bit more steady let me
put it to you this way and this is my
words not theirs i'm going to paraphrase
kind of what they say
they would not be 7-0 without kade
mcnamara being their starting
quarterback in fact there's a good
chance that they can't get to 12-0 or
11-1 without j.j mccarthy playing more
significant role or even being their
starting quarterback moving forward
okay so if you start to to think about
this and i think that they had a long
view to begin the season where they know
like listen in order to give ourselves
the best chance to win
cade's gotta play he's not gonna turn
the ball over we know we're very good up
front on our offensive line we've got
these two great backs and we're just
gonna be able to bludgeon people to
death really and and win games now if we
can get through wisconsin on the road or
nebraska on the road
and and we can win those games we're
going to set ourselves up for a chance
to make a run here late in the season
late october and november now having
said that rather than just put all their
chips in that basket they understand
that kate mcnamara probably has a lid or
a ceiling to where he can take the
offense i wouldn't categorize him as an
above the x's and o's player here's how
i would play uh put it they don't have a
wide receiver right that takes cage game
to the next level and kade doesn't take
any other wide receivers game to the
next level
jj does potentially but he's the
unbroken cult
that you know you get on and you're like
you just don't know so you don't want
them to buck you off against wisconsin
or washington early in the season and
lose you a game with with a with a poor
interception or a mistake but at the
same time you know that that ceiling
that kate has on his on this offense may
need to be ratcheted up and that that
lid may need to come off of that offense
at some point down the stretch maybe
it's this week so they played him and it
wasn't just small packages they gave him
the offense and would allow him to play
in big moments and and shuttle him in at
times so now if then when they need to
go to jj mccarthy he's not an unknown
commodity they're not quote replacing
the quarterback they're just giving him
an expanded role within the offense i
think it's been very smart from them
they understand what they're going to
need here in the back half of the season
and i think they're more prepared to
answer some of those questions if and
when they arise than maybe they have
been in the past what um what a backdrop
right for six versus eight uh a big time
rivalry in college football for the big
ten
top ten match up
where where michigan state
uh with mel tucker rumored maybe to be
um a a coach in the in the eye
of other teams that might want to hire
him and then obviously harbaugh this
stage of his career as the coach and a
kid that might come in at quarterback
and put some spice in it i mean you and
gus have got quite the piece of filet
mignon served up there's no doubt in
particular when you know that this this
match up the ohio state matchup these
types of matchups right you know
anybody else in college football can
point to a 7-0 record and everyone would
be like man our coach is getting it done
this year we're so excited not in
michigan i don't know everyone's just
sitting back and you're like okay let's
see it on october 30th you know let's
see it on november 27th um
that fan base you included i think would
fall into that yeah i'm i'm actually
thrilled that with this it's been a
while man you know and i i like it i
like seeing the fun that they're having
and you know i mean pat 40 with a great
story about a fun house that harbaugh's
building right the football fun house or
something
i kind of dig it and of course michigan
state just wants to just wipe them might
wipe the floor with them um you know
personally just to put a button on this
and we'll talk about some other college
football stories uh i think michigan has
been preparing for this game all year
that they're built to win a game like
this it's just what happens you know
on thanksgiving weekend that's i i don't
know if they've got that firepower if
it's going to be a 40 to 30 you know a
50 to 40 game or something like that i
don't know that's why mccarthy's such a
fascinating figure to me exactly and
this is why i can't wait to see
like when when is it when he gets 50 of
the snaps or 60 of the snaps right what
what drives do they need it the most
when they need his legs to affect the
defense and his ability to throw it down
the field
it's it's it's so fascinating and i love
it this is why i love college football
and you're right that the mentality of
this team is far different than the
teams previous that i've covered at
michigan uh there is an an element of
love of the game that's maybe a little
higher uh and love of each other to be
honest with you i know that's hard to
measure and talk about but this is a
team that really loves football i think
led by hassan haskins and aiden
hutchinson those two guys set the tone
hutchinson being one of the best players
in college football guy that no doubt
you know you and i will be talking about
come springtime when it comes to the nfl
draft is one of the top um
draft picks next year so um it's just a
fast it's a fascinating game uh and
by the way
michigan state if they if they win this
and sets the world on fire sure does
right like
lsu is going to be banging down their
door if they win this game for their
head coach and they're going to be
saying please don't leave us they
already gave them five and a half
million dollars to be there which you
know for a guy that hadn't won as a head
coach is a lot of money they're paying
his ass assistance a lot of money i
think the pool for their assistance plus
the head coach is somewhere over 11
million bucks
so you know spartan land this is a big
one there too certainly sets up the week
weekend before thanksgiving at ohio
state for michigan state and then the
weekend of thanksgiving versus penn
state that that that could be for all
the
the shooting match for who i guess would
would take on iowa one would think in
the other in the other conference uh i
know that other side of the division is
so fascinating with purdue beating iowa
right wisconsin still technically
controls their own destiny kind of
so i mean it's uh there's also purdue's
still alive iowa is alive like it's it's
all over the map joel klatt few more
minutes left with joel klatt who's
calling michigan michigan state uh on
saturday at noon with gus johnson um and
the rest of the fox crew on uh joining
me here on the rich eisen show
here's a story line let's front load it
for december can a guy who comes in the
middle of a season be considered a
heisman trophy candidate in caleb
williams in in uh oklahoma what do you
think of that i i i think that you could
consider him a candidate and and that's
as far as i'll go um i just i i believe
in honoring the totality of the season
i don't believe that that he should win
the heisman trophy because he has not
played the requisite games and i know
that there's not you know some number
but part of being the best player in
college football is being the best
player in college football for your team
for the entire season and and we haven't
it's totally unprecedented for a guy to
miss even a couple of games and win the
heisman trophy so
while it's a great story and and i love
what he's doing for that team
he's still
to me
somewhat of a they almost lost to kansas
you know and and i know it wasn't
because he played poorly but at some
point you know that has to weigh into
your equation in particular when you've
got guys that
i think have put together a better full
body of work to be quite honest with you
i think bryce young's body of work is is
better than caleb uh
williams i i think that matt corral's
body of work kenny pickett's body of
work cj stroud's body of work um
kenneth walker at michigan state i mean
there's there's guys all over the place
that have a better full body of work
than what caleb does and i don't want to
be a prisoner of the moment to see what
this kid is doing uh while it's amazing
i i don't believe that he should win the
heisman trophy well i've i've never seen
a player joel
spark a replay review
because he has stolen the ball away from
his own ball carrier to make sure
there's a first down on fourth down i've
never
seen that before but
i did see it against kansas and and yeah
you but you
yeah they they almost lost to kansas
but there's always that clunker right
when when you go on the road in in
conference
with against somebody that that can hang
their entire season on a one win that
day against you
and they didn't have suffer that loss
because of this kid yeah you know and
that's that play i think uh was
it was one of the more impressive plays
i've ever seen in my entire life and and
yeah
i love watching him and i don't want to
diminish him as a player that doesn't
mean that i don't think he's not great
because he is and he has sparked this
this team to
um i think
a much better version of themselves uh
you look in particular their run game
they've averaged 220 yards or more
a game in those three games since he's
taken over that that was vastly
different than what they were under
spencer rattler in large part due to the
fact that he's contributing not only
with those like 75 rush yards per game
but he's threatening the defense his
ability to make throws down the field on
time and more in rhythm that one rattler
was doing is is tremendous and
having said that a lot even with that
moment ripping the ball away from
kennedy brooks in order to save a
victory
i just don't think he's played enough
games
yeah
again just uh i i hear you and i agree
with you i've just never seen somebody
create a play where the officials say
let's stop we got to take a look at that
yeah like what's going on is that legal
that's amazing and i was like is that
legal
oh it's amazing um last one for you here
uh the uh carson palmer mentioned of
mike tomlin's name uh for usc's open
candidacy on our buddy dan patrick's
show look uh when i was in high school
christy brinkley was on my wish list too
so hey you know just
breaking news um so uh
what do you make of of that and where do
you think the usc coaching search is if
they're really spending time on mike
tomlin which i think is a non-starter
clearly well so i i think that swinging
big is fine and and i think that usc
does have cachet um and and i don't
think that they
have to limit themselves now having said
that i i loved what mike said
um i love what i i mean that's how you
turn a job down and i think it's also by
the way i love that it might be sneaky
brilliant to chan to challenge
billionaires about the size of their
blank checks
that's that was the best part for me i
was like
he was like there's not a big enough
blank check and i'm like really like
are we have you met dr dre
now having said that the only part that
that i thought was
was interesting that he bristled that
and i understand it was heat of the
moment but when he's talking about andy
reid he's talking about sean payton
right with all due respect to mike
tomlin those guys weren't mentioned by
carson palmer who's part of the search
committee for the open position so this
this had nothing to do with a
disrespectful question to him personally
in fact the journalist who asked the
question was just doing their job so i
have a little bit of a problem of
getting on a soapbox and making it seem
like the question is absolutely
ridiculous it's not a ridiculous
question because of what was reported by
carson palmer if you want to get mad at
carson palmer that's fine john harbaugh
doesn't get mad when he gets mentioned
for college jobs which happens more
regularly than when when it happens for
mike tomlin this has been the first time
and he's got what i would consider to be
a very similar style resume and style
job in the national football league a
very good organization that's having a
lot of success a deep tenure a good gm
over a course of a couple of different
gm's just like mike tomlin and and he
gets asked about it as well and doesn't
have a blow up moment so while i want to
praise like that's how you turn a job
down it also shouldn't have gotten
personal as if like how dare they ask me
about it it's like listen your name was
brought up you're going to get the
question
i think part of it might be that
palmer's a bengal
you know or originally was at least i
know that's what steelers it's all over
the place right yeah i know himself like
how do i help my old organization here's
how i do the best the easiest way to be
defeated is be distracted so he just
threw a distraction grenade right in
there to the pittsburgh steelers sneaky
brilliance by palmer well joel oh man i
wish i at some point let's all hope that
we're in a position to challenge a
billionaire about the size of their
blank check
joel klatt thanks for the call uh and
once again uh you will have my emotions
you and gus um in in the palms of your
hands and your headsets and um i i will
be glued i will be glued and hopefully a
joyous by the end of the day but i i
know uh the call will be great you guys
are awesome thanks for the call i
appreciate that rich have a good man
hook up later in the year okay you got
it that's joel klatt right here on the
rich eisen show love that guy man
love that guy
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here